so it just goes on under here like this
that's right
oh God yeah you never get used to that
hey just want to check in see how you're
doing I am so great he's great we're all
great 12 dogs
this is my life now I'm a dog nurse look
at that one though he's smiling yeah he
should be it's his first day without a
muzzle
hi champion champion
oh my gosh there you are puppy that is a
three-legged dog his name is champion
because he's the dog world champion okay
I have to ask this I'm sorry but how
many legs did that dog have when you
found him three that's what makes him
the best he can do more with three legs
than most dogs can do with four except
for digging he's really bad at digging
and we remember what you said about
making decisions in the house you want
to be involved we get that so you just
say the word and Champion goes back to
the pound where you can be put down and
killed forever
I'm not gonna send a three-legged dog to
his death yes but I'm also not gonna
take care of him for you well it would
be nice if you helped a little
because unlike you Andy and I have jobs
cruel but fair in times of stress or
moments of transition sometimes it can
feel like the whole world is closing in
on you
when that happens you should close your
eyes take a deep breath listen to the
people who love you when I give you
advice
and remember what really matters
and if you have the ability to go to
Paris by all means go to Paris you will
now wrestle my cousin mom no okay all
right all right
you're a freak I'm not doing this
anymore this is over but don't Ryan you
don't have to wrestling Ryan
[Music]
Ryan
hi Ryan
you see nice
we're all animals
and daughters
[Music]
so I forgot about this old custom if a
man is interested in courting a woman he
may throw the beaks of a crow
at her and then if she's interested in
accepting the courtship she has to
destroy the beats
[Music]
down
can I talk to you guys about something
actually Teddy this is not a good time
we're still having a pretty big fight
well I think what I'm about to say
myself things
Amy I'm still in love with you what what
what oh
a skip is
super uncomfortable
jazz
hey guys
um you know what we cannot shoot this ad
today
okay when should we come back how about
never 100 hours sir
wait we were sent here to help I'm not
gonna argue with this guy let's go
good luck dude hey thanks thank you
thank you
I'm Trish
um I'm 22 years old I've been on YouTube
um I just I love to hang out with my
friends I love to laugh I love the
summertime and going to the beach and I
love wearing bikinis at the beach with
everyone there I just want well you know
I can't help me winners are you having a
good time
[Applause]
did you pick a new chair it's been a
while Pam when I first opened this
catalog
I thought I was just going to be picking
out a chair but instead you found
something to distract you from ever
picking out a chair
have you ever seen this woman
her the one in the really great mesh
black high back swivel chair her smile
his eyes look at her eyes she's got I
don't know what it is exactly she
dresses like a professional and yet you
know there is a side of her that could
just curl up on a couch or in a great
chair oh yeah maybe but love
[Applause]
okay
that was horrible because I didn't get a
chance to rap pop
dropping bodies it's a stick up
no Hitchcock there's no rapping you've
grossly misread the situation this is
going to be the best Christmas ever my
girlfriend Carol is coming to our party
tonight and I have a little surprise for
her
I've got two tickets to paradise
pack your bags we'll leave and day after
tomorrow
um taking her to sandals Jamaica all
inclusive
all inclusive renewal Diamond range
[Music]
good morning everyone I'm April Ludgate
and I will be filling in for Leslie
while she runs for office
so the new emergency protocol for the
parks department can be found in your
binders what exactly is the chain of
command vis-a-vis on-site response you
know what why don't we just say that
whoever gets to the emergency first will
be in charge okay so if there's an
explosion say in Ramset Park and someone
from sewage gets there first they'd be
in charge
end stop and frisk stop racial profiling
unlawful arrest is a crime can I say I
think Gina was right about the campaign
sir
I'm surprised he hasn't marched in here
to say I told you so she wouldn't do
that you're you're right Amy
for once in your life you're 100 right I
would never say that
did you have enough time to read at all
yes okay good
without further ado
the one the only
the sexy Mr Benjamin Franklin
thank you for that introduction Mr Scott
and good afternoon fine gentle women of
Dunder Mifflin huh
half pants right Mr Franklin knickers in
fact yes he's in his knickers Mr
Franklin I would say you are probably
one of the sexiest presidents ever well
actually I never was president
oh no
hold still
I'm gonna hide behind you like your tree
um why are you doing that on the other
side of your trunk is the worst person
I've ever met Captain Jeffrey Boucher
the living embodiment of evil Raymond
halt
you have not aged a day so how's Kevin
how's cheddar come on tell me everything
Kevin is fine cheddar is a dog he has no
concept of good or bad I wouldn't be so
sure about that he's a very clever dog
hey I wanted to tell you that I am also
running for the board of directors you
were what yeah I had no idea that you
were running but listen it doesn't
matter because you're gonna win anyway I
mean you're Ray Holt but look I gotta go
I will see you soon I hope not